welcome to lecture 18 of
1413 this lecture is about gender
discrimination and identity
okay so what's the agenda today we're
going to talk about gender and identity
and particularly discrimination
first i'm going to give you a broad a
quick overview of why this is an
important
area to study then i'm going to give you
an
equally brief um overview of the gender
gap
what wages the fact that women earn less
money than men
for equal work how that has
evolved over time and how much still is
left of this gender gap
then we're going to talk a little bit
about potential technological solutions
can we use technology to improve um or
to reduce discrimination
potentially and the answer will be yes
to some extent but technology will not
solve everything
then we're going to talk about two
particular important issues one is
beliefs and people's um
updating about beliefs when it comes to
like man and woman and their skills
um and then we're going to talk about
gender identity norms in particular
um which is the idea that people's
deeply held beliefs about what should be
done in society or not might affect
their
behavior and finally we're going to talk
a little bit about
demand and supply for different tasks
so in particular i'm going to show you
that women are
more likely to say yes to what's called
non-promotable tasks tasks that are good
for society but perhaps not good for
their career
or tasks that are good for like a
company or university as a whole
but are not good not promotable in the
sense that they they help women in fact
i get promoted women are more likely to
say yes to those things
in addition on top of that precisely
because they're more likely to say yes
they're also more likely to be asked in
the first place which sort of amplifies
that difference i'm going to tell you
about this in more detail the first
question you might ask is why
study gender differences i have four
answers for you
the first one is simple equity fairness
and justice issues
people simply should be rewarded equally
for the same output
so if a man and a woman works equally
many hours and is equally productive
they should be paid the same
and if that's not the case that's not
and that's unequal that's unfair or not
unjust or not justified now
there might be an additional uh equity
and fairness issues that
men and women might not even be allowed
to work as much um
women might not be allowed to work as
much as men that's an additional sort of
fairness
concern second there's an efficiency
argument which is
overall productivity in welfare falls if
women and other groups are held back by
discrimination and other distortions
and indeed a substantial share of recent
u.s growth can be explained by the
improved allocation of talent in the
economy
so this is just a simple idea that well
if
we exclude certain groups including
women from
certain jobs the most talented people in
those groups
will not be allowed to some of the most
talented people in those groups might
not be allowed to do those jobs
and that's bad for society overall think
about for example doctors if women
cannot be doctors
well then we will essentially just
exclude a large fraction of the most
talented people in terms of like being
doctors
the smartest brightest and hardest
working
women and that will be worse
not just for those women but it will
also be bad for medical
medical care innovation and so on in the
medical profession
because it's we just essentially exclude
some of the best people from
that type of work and if you want to
learn more about this the people that i
see it all
is an excellent sort of discussion of
these issues
third we might learn about the
formation of preferences and personality
by studying gender
and here the idea is that there are in
many cases differences
in preferences such as risk preferences
social preferences
and taste for competition or
competitiveness
but also in attitudes towards
negotiation or other things such as
identity aspirations or over
under confidence more generally well
so if there are these differences at
later ages we can sort of learn about
the formation of those preferences and
personality
um by uh looking for instance at like
people at different ages and uh trying
to understand at which ages
those differences emerge for instance
you might um
look at like five-year-olds or
ten-year-olds fifteen-year-olds and look
at their risks on social preferences
and then try to understand when those
gender gaps
emerge over time and that will allow us
then to understand
questions of nature versus nurture
whether there are
inherent differences in preferences and
personality overall just men and women
are just
different inherently for some reason or
um it could be that
it's really about socialization and
education and the like
girls and boys are just treated very
differently by their parents
by their social environments their
teachers and so on and that might create
such differences in preferences
and other behaviors so that's another
reason to study those
you're gonna mostly focus on number one
just simply the idea that are the
objectives that people should be
rewarded
equally for the same um output
now what is the gender gap or what do i
mean when i talk about the gender gap
so claudia golden who is a um abnormal
researcher at harvard
who has done a lot of seminal work on
gender at the economics of gender
he's written a very nice overview paper
in 2014 and
giving an overview of what what do we
know and how far
we come and trying to reduce and close
the um
gender gap um the graph that i'm showing
you here
summarizes this discussion fairly well
um it's a bit of a messy graph so let me
show you what it shows i'll tell you
what it shows
on the x-axis you see people's age from
20 to 70.
on the y-axis you see the log of
female-to-male earnings for average
female-to-male earnings which is
essentially a measure of the gender gap
and so the difference in blog is
essentially the percentage difference
in uh female versus male earnings so
minus 0.3 you would think of that as
that as like 30 difference in
female versus male 1 earnings what do we
see here real
a we see like a pretty large gender gap
anywhere in this graph
i should have also said different lines
are now different chords
um so these are like starting in 1923
and he said people born in 1923
28 33 38 to 43 and so on and five-year
intervals
from the the oldest to like more recent
um chords
now what do we see we see a significant
gender gap everywhere in this graph
or in all lines of the graph we see that
the gender gap even for the most recent
quartz seems to be about 20 to 30
percent
we see that the gender gap has um fallen
so when you look at like the most
um the oldest chords the tinder gap was
even larger
than the more recent cohorts we also see
that there's sort of this
u shape but we seem to find that the
gender gap
starts emerging already at like age
27 28 30 there's already a gender gap of
something like 10 to 15 percent
even for the most recent cohorts but
then that gender gap gets magnified
towards like you know 20 30 40
um uh until like about age 40 to 45 when
it's sort of like plateau so maybe like
um
falls a bit um or overall
so what do we learn here well we say
well there's substantial
female labor market gains over the last
half century but large gender gaps
remain in 2010 for instance the ratio of
mean annual earnings between male and
female workers
is that people who worked full-time full
year 20 to 25 to 69 years
was 0.72 and that of the median was 0.77
notice that these the figure here uh
controls for work time and education
so while of course it might also be the
case and it's indeed the case that women
work
fewer hours and days than men do even
conditional and work time education
is a significant gender gap remaining of
something like 20 to 30 percent
that women are paid less for equal
pork now first
what are some of the reasons why there
have been substantial female
labor market gains over the last half
century well
um there's quite a few uh technological
and other explanatory factors
one uh big factor was reduction in the
gender gap and education women are just
more able and can afford
to receive education that's true for
both primary secondary
education but also in particular for
university or higher
higher education more generally second
there's been technological innovations
such as the pill dishwasher and so on
which
allowed women to do more work outside of
the household
there have also been like labor demand
shifts in particular as the us economy
has been
moving from manufacturing and
agriculture towards
services women tend to have comparative
advantages
in services compared to like a
particular hard
manual and so these labor demand shifts
and have disproportionately
benefited women finally there's been
also lower discrimination in particular
stronger regulatory controls and
increased market competitiveness
for the latter it's here that if there's
more competition
firms cannot afford to discriminate as
much
because it's actually a costly thing to
do to to hire incompetent men
compared to competent women
now we're going to now discuss the
people by golden brows
which is an example of a simple
technological solution
in particular it's the question whether
blind auditions and orchestras
increase gender ratios in those
orchestras so you know is the fact that
people uh
uh like the blind auditions were
introduced did that contribute
to the increase in the gender ratio in
orchestras
what do i mean by the increase in gender
ratios in the orchestras
so even until the 1960s 70s and 80s
there have been shockingly low female
ratios in
top orchestras and orchestras more
generally
now um these ratios were below 10
and in many orchestras um
and only recently in the 80s and 90s in
particular there have been like stark
increases
in the number of women who play or in
those orchestras
um this increase
um was the case in the top five
orchestras
but also has been uh have been similar
improvements in generations in other
orchestras which you can read
the report that i linked in the uh
in the slides now um one
really important reason here uh seems to
have been
um blatant sexism even by very renowned
or particularly by renowned
conductors which you can have not gonna
repeat here but you can read it in
section one of the paper by golden
browns
and so one question is like well is is
does this
sexism and discrimination has that
contributed
to um the low gender
ratio in uh in orchestras now
um while there have been all these
improvements in the
gender ratio and like musicians in
general
there still are vast differences in
conductors and the number of conductors
and music directors they're essentially
predominantly male still moreover
while there have been a lot of
improvements in terms of gender
most musicians are still white
so um african-americans and latinos are
very much underrepresented in orchestras
now let me tell you a short decide about
women in economics
this is not just the case that an
orchestra on the fraction of women is
low
that's also true in economics
um and here's sort of an overview of
that there's a
quite nice overview paper by moonberg
and stearns in 2019 which sensei says
that some progress has been made but
lots more needs to be done and more
recently in particular
some of the progress seems to have
stalled
what would we mean by that well here
this graph shows the fraction
of women in different stages in the
profession
ranging from senior majors here at the
top
to first year phd students to assistant
professors
new phds assistant professors associate
professors and
for professors and what you see here
there seems to be some trend that's
upwards in particular for full
professors and associate professors
which is
which is of course good um there uh
there's less of a positive friend to be
seen when in particular when it comes to
assistant professors you know theories
you essentially see
since 2000 about 2007 uh
or six has been no increase if anything
like a decrease in the fraction of
female assistant professors
but even like the fraction of phd
students is
clearly below 50 and so
the profession is starting to understand
and address address the issues in
particular to try to reduce
a and other issues holding women back
there's for example some particularly
nice examples of the cement
mentoring programs which are trying to
support female and minority uh assistant
professors and in terms of mentoring and
trying to sort of foster their careers
which has um uh been shown to
impact and significantly uh improved the
profession
but what it's worth in 1413 and the
majority of
students tends to be female and moreover
the best students tend to be female
as well so very much hope you are still
interested and
all female students are very much still
interested in economics and will pursue
a career in economics perhaps
academically
now back to orchestras so many
orchestras introduced blind editions in
the 1970s and 1980s
and if you look back at the graph that i
showed you um this graph here you see in
the
1970s 80s and 90s that's also the time
when there was a sharp increase
in the uh share of women in industrial
stress
so um you can see here in the graph
orchestras do you want to get a job in
orchestras you have to do auditions
these auditions are very very
competitive and often have like several
stages they're preliminary semi-finals
and finals and many orchestras
what you see here is uh 11 anonymized
orchestras including the top orchestras
in the us
and the introduction of blind editions
in those orchestras
what you see is that most orchestras did
introduce blind editions at least in
some of their stages of the additions
however many of them also only introduce
it in some stages but not in others
now you can think already that that's
not
sufficient in some cases if you have
only like blind auditions in the
preliminaries but not in the semi-finals
or finals
you might sort of reduce discrimination
in the preliminaries but then if women
are discriminated in the semi-finals or
finals
that's not going to help them get hired
which at the end of the day we of course
care about
now golden and bruce look at
technological solutions and and
look at the question of whether such
technological solutions in fact can help
now the question they're asked now is
looking at data from actual additions
often using individual fixed effects
do these blind emissions the
introduction of blind auditions
help candidates reach the next round or
particularly
get hired now the data is
fairly rich and often includes or allows
for the
inclusion of individual fixed effects
that is the case if you look at the
musicians
golden rules are going to ask the
question is a particular
musician more likely to
make it to the next round when auditions
are blinded
and is that more likely the case for
female than for a male
uh musicians now what do they find
overall they find evidence that
blind conditions plan audition
procedures fostered impartiality in
hiring
and increase the proportion of women in
century orchestras
now there's some caveats here that you
know some of these estimates are fairly
precise in particular at later stages
because the number of
observations was quite a bit down quite
a bit there's um
some of these results are a little bit
mixed but overall the evidence suggests
that these blind editions
did indeed foster impartiality and
helped women
succeed in getting jobs in particular in
these top orchestras
in the us now
why are these results perhaps somewhat
less clear cut i already told you like
one reason is that
in later rounds the number of
observation gets kind of small because
you know only so many people make it to
the later rounds
but there's another reason which is the
auditions on several rounds
not all of which were blinded now if
there's one
uh if there's discrimination in one
round but not in the next one
this issue that in the next round there
will be like selection
in a uh the discriminated people who
make it to the next round
you expect them to do better right if
there's discrimination
against women in the first round um but
not in a second
you think that like women in the second
round will do better because only the
best woman will make it to the second
second round
uh because otherwise they will be um
screened out in the first round due to
discrimination right and if that's the
case then like making comparisons in
later
rounds is potentially biased or
problematic
because you're comparing essentially
different types of people in different
routes
and that and that might might lead to
the results being less clear-cut
overall let me give you another example
suppose
um a male and female workers get graded
in that task to put a
pose that's a quoting task online where
you essentially see the output but you
also see their gender
now suppose women get rated
systematically worse due to sexism and
no other reasons because women and men
are exactly the same in the work they do
but some men are sexist and they're
going to rate women worse
now for any given score you should
expect the women
a woman that you hire compared to any
other random man that you hire to do
better
than that man and the reason being that
they have been like systematically
disadvantaged
due to the sexism in the rating to start
with
now you should think about this because
you know there's also some
evidence of teaching evaluations being
biased against women
now if you see a man and a woman with
the exact same teaching rating
well you probably want to take the
woman's class because the woman has been
the female professor has been
discriminated to start with
having that high score or this really
high score as the male professor
is is more impressive and likely to
indicate that the class will be better
there's an excellent people by born and
all that considers the issue of
the dynamics of discrimination in much
more detail if you're interested in
learning more about that
now despite those technological
solutions and advances that i mentioned
you use substantial
substantial gender gaps
remain so while as i told you
the gender gaps has been reduced both in
terms of labor market or labor force
participation
how many days and hours how many women
overall how many days and hours since
we're in work
and in their wages and earnings how much
they're being paid
conditional on working
there there are still substantial gender
gaps
in particular women's labor market
participation has plateaued since
the early 1990s and even now among
entering courts women still earn
significantly less than men
and that's true even for conditional
unwork time education that's the graph
that i was showing you earlier
now given that there are these
persistent remaining gender gaps
even though a lot of the technological
and other barriers have been reduced now
women
are educated or as educated as men are
and there's less technological barriers
that uh preclude women from working
researchers have now started to consider
it somewhat less traditional within
economics
factors including things such as risk
attitudes
negotiation skills teams for competition
but also this is what we're going to
focus on beliefs
and social norms and identity
i'm going to first talk about beliefs
and then we're going to talk about
social norms and identity
um before we get to beliefs about gender
people's women's and men's skills i'm
going to tell you very briefly about a
seminal paper by
bertrand and mulanathan from 2004 that
randomizes
randomized names and job applications
so what did bertrand and volunteon do
they essentially
um send out job obligations that were
otherwise identical
male and female workers these are
fictitious job applications
and they sent them to employers and then
looked at
callback rates by those employers and
the only thing that was like varied in
those applications was
the name on the application and what did
they do while they used
white sounding names such as emily and
greg as well as
african-american sounding names such as
lakisha and jamal
and then they looked at well were these
um uh
applications when they had white
sounding names and were
otherwise identical more successful than
applications
by uh names with african-american
sounding uh
from african-american sounding names and
again that were otherwise identical and
uh
bertrand and mulanathan find the
striking key result that
callback rates for white sounding names
were fifty percent higher than for
african-american sounding
that's a huge difference um and that's
important not just because it's like a
hassle because you have to send out more
applications
well if you get called back more you're
more likely to be
interviewed or asked for an interview
you're more likely to actually get the
job you're more likely to
less likely to be unemployed and
you might also be less likely to just
stop
searching whatsoever because you might
be disappointed or discouraged
so that's a huge difference and
essentially
a discrimination against
african-americans
was plainly obvious from this research
numerous other studies show gender and
racial biases
in various ways these are ranging
from very similar studies including
these audit studies where people are
sent resumes for the like
um but also arranging two studies where
like people on ebay
try to sell things where like they try
to sell like an ipod drive
iphone and they hold that iphone um with
a hand that's either like white
or or non-white and then they find
essentially that
white hands are more likely to sell
their
iphones than non-white hats now this is
a very important
and depressing result one thing to flag
here that it's hard
to distinguish statistical from t space
discrimination
you can talk more about this in in
recitation what do i mean by that
well it might be that there's uh people
have a preference
for white applicants that is to say
controlling for performance
it might just be that people are racist
and they'd rather have like white
applicants than
african-american applicants this is what
economists would call
uh taste based discrimination uh which
essentially is conditional on the
performance
people just like certain types of people
better than others and therefore they
call them are more likely to call them
back
a different explanation is a
belief-based explanation
it might be that employers think that
african-american applicants will perform
worse
even controlling for all other aspects
of the resume so it could be essentially
you see
people see this name and they think that
well even if the resume is good that
person will not perform
as well as somebody with a white
sounding name notice that these beliefs
could be
correct or not um uh but in any case we
will uh and that's you will talk about
this in recitation as well
uh autonomous again would call this
statistical discrimination this could be
again correct statistical exclamation
or statistical discrimination that's uh
based on biased beliefs but either way
these things um
jointly um led to clear discrimination
of african-american applications
which in turn that leads to uh striking
differences
in unemployment or job-finding
rates rates across races we're going to
now focus on
beliefs in particular about beliefs
about skills and how people
update on those beliefs depending on the
gender of the person they're updating on
the paper we're going to consider now is
the people by star since 2019
which considers how people interpret
signals in the labor market
the question that sarson asks is whether
somebody's gender
influences the way how we interpret
information about
this person and about his or her peers
what do i mean by that well uh in many
situations when people
do certain tasks and perform at work
good things and bad things happen now
you can infer
from those things that occur from these
events you can infer
something about their competence and
their performance
now many of these situations are
ambiguous in the sense it could be that
the person was just really lucky
or it could be that the person is really
really good at what they're doing
now what sarcasm is asking when we see
those events so when people see those
events
are people interpreting those events
differently for men versus women
so for example if a man if something bad
happens at work
a boss might react to that
person differently or a
updates their beliefs about the person's
skills differently depending whether
it's man or woman
in addition the boss might also
update differently about the peers
so if a woman makes a mistake the boss
might not only
update his beliefs about
this woman but also about all other
women that worked for him
similarly for a man of course the boss
might do the same
and what heather sarsous now asks is the
question but
is this updating or the interpretation
of information differently
for male versus female workers
now why do we care well we care a lot
about this because hiring promotion
and wage decisions hinge on information
about worker's ability
and in particular if this is thematic
differences in how information about men
and women is interpreted
that could lead to differences in hiring
promotion and wage decisions and in turn
might contribute to the gender gap
what does sarsons do to answer this
question she looks at how do
physicians change referrals to surgeons
and appears
after a patient after certain patient
outcomes
now um what i mean by that well
physicians often refer
patients needing surgery to a local
surgeon so somebody breaks their
arm or the leg while many physicians
can't do this on their own so they will
refer
this patient to a local surgeon
now the referral choice reflects the
physician's beliefs about
the surgeon's ability right you wanna
you wanna
do the best for your um uh patient
and you wanna uh send that patient your
patient to like the best possible
surgeon
so if you have the suspicion if you
think a certain surgeon is not
competent you better not send your
patient to that surgeon
in part because you might care a lot
about the patient in part because you
know
um uh if you make bad referrals that
might also reflect on you
eventually now what does sarson's do
specifically
she um to document whether um the
reaction
uh depends on the surgeon's gender what
does a
surgeon's do she matches on uh surgeon
and patient characteristics under
procedures
that is to say she takes male and female
surgeons
and patient characteristics and
procedures which is like you know
broken arms versus like more complicated
procedures
so she matches all of these
characteristics and such that in your
observations that she has
surgeons only differ by gender and then
she considers what we call like
an event study which is comparing how
physicians react
to um male and female surgeons when good
and bad things
um happen let me now show you more
precisely what we mean
so we have here on the x-axis quarters
on the y-axis we have the referrals from
the physicians to the performing surgeon
so these are essentially diets of pears
or physicians and performing
surgeons and you see here minus one is
normalized to be zero
zero and then essentially you see the
evolution of
the referrals from a specific position
to a performing
surgeon these are men and women and
these are essentially cases in which
there is no adverse event
what are adverse events are like a
patient's death for example
what you see here essentially these are
men and women that are matched they're
supposed to look exactly the same
and what we see here is that referrals
increase over time
uh uh they tend to sort of increase uh
fairly steeply over time and then sort
of plot to go off over or
over time the exact shape and pattern of
this relationship
doesn't matter as much however what
matters is that men and women look
uh exactly on the same right so
the performing surgeon is here the
gender here that varies is the gender of
the performing surgeon
now then she looks at sarcasm looks at
cases in which there is an adverse event
again the adverse event happens around
here
so what you see here is that when there
is an adverse event
there's a clear punishment in the sense
that like
the male surgeon now gets fewer
referrals
from the from the physician
right after the adverse event happens
this is manifested by the blue bars
being lower than
the gray bars notice that the number
doesn't go
down it's still above everything here is
above the red line
so it's just the uh um the physician is
not
uh increasing the um referrals over time
anymore or that increase gets dampened
by the adverse event
this is for the male surgeon let's look
at now what happens to the female
surgeon
what we see here is like a clear
difference that opens up
after the adverse event notice that
there's no pre-trends here before it
looks men
and women or female and male surgeons
including the red and the blue bars look
exactly the same
but the bar the difference only opens up
after the adverse event and there's a
pretty large gap you can see that that
shows up in the referrals
and this gap is way larger if you
compare the red versus the
gray lines that's way larger compared to
the gap that emerges between the blue
and the grey lines so we see here is
that
when both men and women are punished in
the sense of receiving fewer referrals
after an adverse event that punishment
is way more severe for female
than for male surgeons now let's do the
same for
uh the absence of a good event or
actually good events that happen where
it's a good event while like
it's essentially a surprisingly good
thing that happened where there's a
complicated surgery and the person does
really well
um what you see here is again sort of
the the the
men and women that look pretty much
exactly the same you can see like here
maybe men are doing slightly better
uh overall but overall these gray lines
look very similar over time
now if there's a good event that happens
you see essentially men get like very
much like rewarded
if the male surgeon does well um
uh he gets rewarded in the sense of like
receiving
a lot more um uh referrals from the pcp
from the
from the doctor now if you do the same
for um
female surgeon again uh female surgeons
benefit from that
but the increase in referrals is
a lot lower than uh for men so again
both men
and women there is a reaction to that
information to a good or bad event
but the reaction tends to be much
stronger much more favorable for men
in terms of the good events men get
rewarded more for the good events
and women get punished more for
vitamins or surprising vitamins that
happen
let me summarize the main results after
a bad outcome after
for example like a patient death there's
a 34 decrease in referrals to female
surgeon
surgeons and there's a stagnation in
referrals to male surgeons so
essentially women tend to be get
punished quite a lot
men a little bit in the sense that like
referrals don't go up anymore but the
punishment is much less
now strikingly physicians are also less
likely to refer
to other female surgeons that is to say
if a female
surgeon if a patient dies for a female
surgeon
the physician is also less likely to
refer
patients or future patients to other
female surgeons these other female
surgeons
nobody has died there so essentially
what seems to be the case is that
um the physicians also are
updating about women or female surgeons
in general
if there is um a negative event that
happens which is sort of very straight
after a good outcome uh such as like
unanticipated survival
uh there's a doubling of referrals to
male surgeons but only a 70
increase in referrals to females and
they are here there's no spillovers to
to to other female surgeons so
so again what we find here well we find
that
women are punished way more for
unexpected bad events
and they're rewarded less for um
unexpected um good events that is to say
it's not just the case that like
uh there's more updating going on in the
sense maybe you learn more from good and
bad events because maybe you have like
less information about men and women to
start with that's not the case here
what is here the case is that there's
more updating or more punishment for
mistakes for women
and less reward for good things that
happen
or good events for for women as well
now why these asymmetries matter
well one important issue here is that
women have fewer chances to make
mistakes
and in particular if there's like
dropping out if like
if women don't get promoted or if they
even drop out
um that leads to like lower skill
accumulation and you know women will be
just less qualified overall in the end
because they have like less chances to
get promoted um
uh uh i get more responsibility and so
on and so forth when i may even drop
out overall and we just have fewer women
in the profession
now moreover usually wage gaps are
measured conditional and skills industry
and position
but if there's biased evaluations that
lead to differences in skills and
positions in the workplace
not only is it the case that women are
receiving like wage gaps conditional on
those skills but they also have
different skills and positions in the
workplace because of biased evaluations
so that's an additional scope for
discrimination and differences in
earnings and so on
and then importantly this is also not a
mistake that can get corrected over time
because if women drop out in particular
then
or if there's no referrals that happen
anymore then the doctor or any other
person might not
receive any signals anymore from women
right if you sort of
update on on a particular person that
this
patient of mine died because i sent them
to that person
if you then think you know this person
is terrible and don't
send any further patients anymore you'll
never learn that this woman was in fact
very much highly qualified
and that was just an accident that could
have happened to anyone
so that's a really important issue that
um so when women are underrepresented
employers see fewer outcomes overall and
if there's updates more after that
outcomes
in particular if there's also updates
about all women then
um there will be fewer chances um uh to
learn
and uh if then when they let go and so
on
uh or less likely to be hired then there
will be no chance of actually correcting
those police
uh strikingly as i told you um what's
really important
um as a result is that it seems to be
like updating
not just about like one specific woman
overall
after the negative events but also about
all other
um other women um
that that get punished for um the bad
event that happens
and if that's the case well if there's
several women in the profession
and all women always have to pay for any
bad events that happen for any woman and
sometimes you know mistakes in fact
happen
that's of course terrible because that
sort of amplifies um
a lot of the updating because uh even if
somebody makes no mistakes whatsoever
negative updates happen on their
performance other women
perform negatively in some ways
now one question you might ask as well
couldn't we just use algorithms machine
learning etc to overcome
such biases right in particular instead
of hiring and so on
couldn't we use um algorithms machine
learning to
to train those algorithms and you know
instead of use computers instead of
humans and then you know
we might get rid of those biases well
one key problem with that is that
algorithms themselves can be biased
now why is that is what we train
algorithms based on human decisions
as an example if you train an algorithm
some companies did based on actual
decisions if you ask the question this
application if you train the algorithm
actual
hiring decisions or interview decisions
where you say well would this person be
um invited or is this person is his
resume likely to be
invited for an interview well if those
interviewing decisions to start with
were biased
based on sexism racism and so on if you
train your algorithm
on it then very much you make that
algorithm bias
as well now crucially
um that's of course uh problematic
and very much would like to avoid that
and so you want to be very careful
but crucially some of these biases can
be
perhaps easier or fixed and perhaps
fixed more easily
than buy a seasoned human decision maker
right if somebody is sexist or race it's
very hard to fix this
at least in the short run however
an algorithm essentially is just doing
whatever we train them to do
so if we build equity concerns into the
objective
function of an algorithm then we can
essentially reduce or even eliminate
these biases explicitly because the
algorithm is explicitly
i'm asked to do so and so this is
fascinating if you want to learn more
about this overall it's a fascinating
talk on discrimination by algorithms and
people by assembling
that i've linked here um in the slides
that you can
that you can watch and write more about
but overall so
so just to say to summarize algorithms
can be biased
but they can also be fixed and that's an
important research agenda that people
have been working on
uh more recently design of fair
algorithms
next we're going to talk about gender
identity norms and a very nice paper by
patrandedal from 2015.
identity considerations were imported
from social psychology into economics
and multiple papers by akolov and
cranton in 2000
particularly in 2000 there's a very nice
book about identity economics if you're
interested in learning more about that
um gender identity norms are an
important
example or application of such norms or
identity considerations
more generally in particular um uh
alcoholic and quantum or
we here as well focus on two social
categories
men and women for simplicity we can also
just talk about
husbands and wives understand that
things are more complicated in reality
but for simplicity we're going to focus
on that for now
um what do we mean by gender identity
well gender identity is something that
changes
payoffs from different actions as
dictated by some prescriptive norms
what might those norms be one one one
would be men should not do women's work
in the house
in the home like cooking cleaning
and so on some men might consider that
as women's work and they
might feel particularly high disutility
from doing so
um if they violate that norm another
norm would be
men should earn more than their wives
now uh husbands now lose identity
experience lower utility and
circumstances when these prescriptions
are violated when the
when he does a housework or when his
wife earns more than half of the
household income notice that wives might
also lose identity
for simplicity we're going to talk more
only about husbands i'm doing so for now
now we're trying to dial particularly
focus on the
the prescription that men should earn
more than their wives
and uh it's important to notice that
this particular gender identity norm
would only matter in a world where a
woman
could um or would not matter in a world
where women
could never earn more than her actual or
potential husband
but if women are held back by
technological factors by education
etc and never even earn
close to as much as their husbands or
potential husbands well then the gender
identity norm is kind of irrelevant
however as women make gains in the labor
market
these such slow-moving gender identity
norms can become increasingly
relevant and particularly increasingly
relevant constraints
so now as women have more and more
earnings potential
and are might be quite likely to earn
more than their husbands
these norm really bite and might hold
women
back now how would you still study this
question empirically
what the idea here and about triangle is
that
well if husbands
lose identity when their wives earn more
than half the household income well then
they will
try to avoid such situations either in
various ways
and particularly by avoiding such
marriages in the first place
but also if those marriages happen they
might that might lead to divorces and so
on and those marriages might break up
so the idea of the paper then is look is
to look for a missing mass
in couples where uh um particular in
places where the husband earns just a
little bit more
um than their one now how do they do
that well they have to look at the
distribution of relative income
using u.s admin data what i mean by
relative income relative income is the
income between the husband and the wife
they'll have essentially they're very
nice survey
data of the survey income and program
participation
these are as a series of representative
national panels
about 70 000 couple level observations
from 1990 to 2004.
this includes couples only uh in which
both husbands and wives are
earning positive income so uh notice
that this is not about like husband and
wife working
at all it's not about women being at
home versus working but it's about
cases where both couples both
spouses have positive income um
their income measures annual total labor
income
plus self-employed income as well
they're using that data
by trying the dial can now compute the
shares of couple earning different
fractions of
of total income so we're going to show
you is the fraction of
the wife as a share of total income in
the household and that's graphed using
20 bits
what does this graph look like you can
see here the share um
earned by the wife and this is the
fraction of couples this is this
overall so this is like all the couples
these are 20 bins this all
adds up to 100 overall and what you see
is perhaps not surprisingly that the
share
the fraction of couple um for which the
share of
earned by the wife is like uh higher
than 50
is not super high that's not surprising
given that men on average are earning
more
than uh so that's not the question here
the question here is
is there a missing mass just about about
50
the idea is if suppose there's some
couples where
women earn 45 or 46 or even 49
there the norm does not cause an issue
or there's no identity problems
because the husband earns somewhat more
and feels happy about it
but as soon as you cross the threshold
to like 51
now there's a problem now the woman
earns more the husband feels
uncomfortable unhappy
um and so on and uh
and that might lead to those marriages
disappearing in various ways
a they might not form in the first place
husband and potential husband and wife
might never even marry
because husband gets like uncomfortable
and does not want to marry somebody who
earns more
second there might be divorces these
marriages might essentially dissolve
because there's lots of conflict in the
household now how does that manifest
here
you can look at like if you come if you
look at the
graph and look at this line here coming
from the left towards 50
you can kind of look at like try to
predict and this is kind of the idea of
the um
the empirical strategy you can try to
predict what fraction would you expect
there to be just about 50 and when you
do that you think you know the fraction
should be about
um uh something like seven percent
should be about here but instead this is
jump
down to about six percent so there's
about one percent of couples are missing
here
there's a missing mass going on here um
which suggests that
there are some marriages that do not
happen or that just get
dissolved um because of those identity
concerns
this is what i already said here there's
a cliff to the right of 0.5 in the
distribution of relative earnings across
couples
and that's an implication of the
prescription that men should earn more
than their lives now what are the
mechanisms behind this
missing mass we're trying to have a
wealth of evidence
additional evidence showing those
mechanisms in particular
they show three mechanisms which is
first missing couples did not form in
the first place so when you look at like
when you just randomly match men and
women um
some of which were men have higher
earnings potential compared to women and
the other way around
the couples where women are earning just
somewhat less than women are just
much less likely or less likely to marry
compared to couples where women are just
earning somewhat less than men
second such couples are less happy and
stable and more likely to end in divorce
so conditional and marrying they're more
likely to get divorced these marriages
just
end unhappily and that's of course then
also contributes to this missing mass
and then third in cases where wives have
higher
earnings potential than their husbands
they decide now to work
less outside of the household or you
know
put in less effort at work so they get
less promoted which then sort of
um pushes down their earnings or you
know increased
husbands earnings in relative terms such
as that in such cases the woman earns
uh less than 50 and that also leads to
that missing mass
in fact what you see here is this
increase in mass going from like 20 to
40 which perhaps is also like the the
reason because some of the mass that's
missing here is pushed here
um to the left now
um in addition to um
working less outside of the household
and just working few hours
like working less overtime and so on um
women then
are also held back by non-market and
child care work so women in particular
women who are
um are earning just a little bit more
than their husbands
are doing more non-market and child care
work which is um often called the second
shift
so the idea here is that husband's ego
or his identity gets like uh
threatened by the woman earning more
than he does
and then he can particularly not do the
child care or non-market work
so the end the woman ends up not only
working more outside of the household
and earning more and being more
productive in that work
but also doing more work uh at home um
and
in addition um to that that's
essentially what's called the second or
double
uh shift
now an additional issue
that is a really important still
contributor to
the gender gap is the arrival of
children
and this is a very nice paper by clavin
and all that looks at
people's earning in particular earning
how earnings evolve after the birth of a
couple's um first
child this is an event study that looks
at uh
years over time for men and women
and what you see essentially for men
these are earnings and on the right here
you have hours worked
for men essentially there's barely any
difference if any difference
of the um of earnings once the first
child is born
essentially men's earnings tend to be
pretty flat in contrast of course there
could be like for the growth that's
avoided but you know at least there's no
reduction in men's learning this is by
the way
danish data now um for women however
um there's a clear reduction in
earnings and um
uh the long-run child penance penalty is
about um
almost 20 so essentially women after
if you look at like men and women that
earn the same to start with
um women earn about 20 less
in the long run uh uh that is due to
like the first child or after that or
that this gap arises after the first
child is born
this is true for earnings it's also true
for hours worked and there the penalty
is about 10
it's also true for wages as unlike how
much are people paid
conditional on uh working so part of
that is women working less
but part of it is also women earning
less
like being promoted less being paid less
getting fewer raises and so on
once that child is born one very
interesting fact is that
in this paper is that child penalties
are transmitted through generations
from parents to daughters suggesting an
influence of child environment on uh
gender identity
there seems to be something about the
gender identity about like
the woman is supposed to take care of
the child
and that runs in the family and that
leads to particularly large
what they call child penalties for those
kinds of
women compared to men
now one thing you might say as well
couldn't we have some gender-neutral
family policies that alleviate that
in particular in academia for instance
one idea is one could use
gender-neutral 10-year clock stopping
policies
um to alleviate such issues
and the idea is that in particular sort
of our early years in the career are
particularly valuable
so the very least we can do is we can
stop the the tenure clocks
to help women or couples to deal with
child care
and many many universities and research
intensive universities in the us
have adopted such what's called
gender-neutral 10-year clock
policies in the us now
uh what do i mean by gender neutral
essentially if a couple um has a child
not only um does the uh
the the woman um if she has given birth
to the child
uh does she get a an extension in the
10-year clock
but also the spouse will get such an
extension as well so it's gender-neutral
in that sense now what would such
policies then do well they intended to
involve
men more in child care and sort of like
foster that
the idea being like if you only give
that extension to
to women it sort of like pushes women to
um
uh take care of
their children and sort of not to do
work and perhaps if we involve
uh both spouses or parents in
in the child care uh uh providing those
gender neutral ten-year clock stopping
policies might contribute to that
but of course there's no enforcement and
that's potentially
of such policies in that potentially
these policies might be
even enhancing gender inequality and
particularly if it's the case that
if men take advantage of this 10-year
clock
stopping policy by essentially just
having another year to do research
but still don't do very much in
supporting the child
then men might actually benefit from it
while women might
not benefit at all in part because
relatively they're going to do worse
compared to men
and um so uh anticoagulant look in fact
at the impact of these adoptions of
these
uh supposedly gender neutral
uh tenure-clock-stopping policies
and they find that um the introduction
of this policy at top 50 economics
department substantially reduced female
10-year rates
by increasing male tenure rates so
essentially what looks like a um
neutral policy in fact is not gender
neutral at all it makes things worse for
women
and um better for men let me tell you
about one final paper on
uh gender gender identity and uh the
labor market
this paper is called acting wife
marriage market incentives and labor
market investments
it's by bush cinel and it asks the
question whether women avoid career
enhancing
actions because these actions signal
undesirable or seemingly undesirable
traits
such as ambition to the marriage market
um there's two parts in the paper um one
part is just observational
data that finds that while married and
unmarried female mba students perform
similarly when their performance is
unobserved by classmates such as on
exams or problem sets
unmarried women have lower participation
grades which are observed by their
classmates
and so the idea here is that only
unmarried female mba
students have uh incentives on the
marriage market and therefore when their
participation
is observed when their performance is
observed
they might want to scale back their
admission
because they look too ambitious on the
marriage mark and then they might be
adversely interpreted by potential
dates and of course married women as
it's already married don't have that
incentives
um so they don't engage in such behavior
as you might know there's lots of dating
uh going on so lots of
mba students are actively looking for a
spouse during their experience both men
and women
now in addition they have a field
experiments with mbas
in which they vary the expectation
whether
responses in a real estate placement
questionnaire
is going to may be made public in
particular whether it's going to be
observed by
their peers and now female
single female students reported lower
desired
salaries and willingness to travel and
work long hours
on those questionnaires when they
expected their classmates to see their
preferences
that is to say when these questions are
public
single female students reported lower
lower ambition as manifested by desired
salaries and willingness to travel in
work hours
presumably because they want to look
more favorable on the marriage market
notably other groups responses were
uninfected by
such pure observation observability so
in other groups it didn't matter whether
it's in public and in private
in addition there's a second experiment
that indicates the effects were driven
by
the observability by single male peers
that is to say if another woman saw
the information that didn't matter so
much but if this other
single male peer were was likely or
possibly going to see that information
then
these effects would um show up so that's
um
overall showing that uh essentially
what's uh
perceived to be undesirable traits um
uh such as ambition um if that that is
perceived to to be damaging on the on
the marriage market
that can then in turn reduce ambition
and then contribute
to the gender gap
overall okay
let me tell you now about a final paper
on uh uh
saying no and on demand and supply for
different tasks
this is a very nice paper by raster
linganelle and asks the question whether
women say no often enough
and so that's motivated by the
observation that female
faculty members spend fewer hours on
research and more hours
on university survey committees than
male faculty
they also are more likely to have
positions on university-wide communities
they advise more undergrad students and
participate more in departments and
college level committees than real
faculty
more generally in mid-level jobs men
more than women evaluate the individual
task assignments as challenging
and this is partially attributed to
differential task assignments by
supervisors
so
if you sort of see that these
differences you might ask the question
why do women
decide to spend or spend their work time
differently
and there's two types of dimensions here
one is demand and one is supply
um so demand is essentially the question
whether uh
sex differences in the types of tasks
that women and men are asked to do
and works is that due to like
essentially what they're being asked
um and i wouldn't more likely than men
to be asked to do what's called
non-promotable tasks tasks that are not
really hopeful for their career for
getting promotions and then you might
ask why that's the case
supply is what other sex differences the
willingness to agree to perform
non-promotable tasks when asked with
conditional i'm being asked a woman more
likely to say
yes and again
are women more likely to demand to say
yes to non-promotable tasks
now why do we care while there's an
individual decision-making perspective
which is that people might make
suboptimal decisions how to allocate
their work
time at work and understand these
underlying reasons potential
intervention better sort of understand
these underlying reasons which will lead
them potentially to some interventions
to improve decision making for
certain individuals which are a lot
about vehicle economics is
but there's also managerial and social
planner perspectives
that organizations may now be using
their resources more
most effectively and if you sort of
reallocated some of the tasks
um uh that would produce that would
increase um
output overall and then finally there's
a public policy perspective well
if these sex differences in the
allocation of time explain
uh vertical sex segregation essentially
like women not being promoted enough
then it would help us sort of improve
gender equity overall and perhaps also
try to
reduce the gender gap now what are these
promotable and non-promotional tasks and
the type of like academics
a promotable task is a task that's doing
research that's essentially what people
are evaluated on eventually
but also in the other tasks essentially
that's seen where other people will
reward you for when you do it and
non-promotable tasks essentially tasks
it often discretionary
many people could do the task and
everybody wants it has to be done yet
everybody prefers somebody else to do it
for example would be an ethics committee
at the university surely we should have
one but surely
sitting on the committee will not help
people get promoted or get tenure when
it comes to research
now um the the authorization that we
were killed studying with faculty
at a large public university and they
sent essentially emails from the chair
of the faculty
senate asking them to to volunteer to
join one of several university-wide
faculty senate committees
and the clear answer in this study is
that women are much more likely to
volunteer
when asked now
that is an interesting fact but that
doesn't really necessarily let us
disentangle the demand and supply
explanation that which that i showed you
previously
so in addition to men uh the authors do
a lab experiments
in which they do what's called the
threshold public goods game
and this is sort of very much trying to
mirror or like
resemble the reality in this game a
small group
needs to find a volunteer for a task and
participants are anonymously matched in
groups of three
they're randomly rematched for each of
10 rounds
the game is set up such that everyone
prefers that the caspian are taken by
someone other than themselves
people get two minutes to decide whether
to invest and so
the task is essentially you have to
click a button and then you invest the
money
only one person can invest the round
ends when somebody invests
if no one invests group members all
earned one dollar
if a person invests that person earns
1.25 and the remaining group of members
earn
two dollars the clock ticks down until
one person invests or no investment is
made in two minutes
so the game is essentially set up in a
way such that that
everybody wants that somebody and it's
included somebody should invest but
nobody wants to mess because
if you invest you get only a dollar 25
well if you don't invest or somebody
else investing you don't invest you get
two dollars
now in this game women are significantly
more likely to invest you essentially
see the probability of resting here on
the left side by
round and the red line which is the
upper line the women line the
female line is way way higher compared
to the male height there's much higher
probability of investing in this game
now why are women more likely to invest
is it the case that women believe that
their cooperation is necessary for an
optimal group decision but men believe
that their
cooperation isn't required so it could
be that women sort of think that they're
like well
somebody uh if i don't do it nobody else
does it
and then essentially think well somebody
else can do it in particular women could
do it if they're in the group
so then the authors do the same
experiment again
um using a single sex sessions
where essentially all three um
people in the session are female or all
people in the session are
are male and then what they find is
essentially interestingly
these differences in gender now go away
entirely there's no gender differences
in same-sex
sessions anymore so just to summarize
so um experiment one when there's a
mixed gender
women are more likely to invest in
experiment two women and men
are equally likely to invest now one
question you might ask as well
is it the case that really um is this
really about beliefs so it could be that
like
um there's no in fact no differences in
the preferences for investing it's not
like women are necessarily nicer than
men
but rather their differences and beliefs
that the women
will invest in particularly if there's a
woman in the group everybody else may
think oh the woman is going to invest
and the woman might think like well if
others don't invest
or others will not invest and since she
might believe that she might have to or
like think that she needs to do it
herself
otherwise um everybody will end up with
one dollar and less money
so now there's a third experiment here
um
where people ask um
to essentially pick whom they would like
to to ask
and so there's four people per group and
three people can invest and the
incentives are four these are like
they're called the green players and one
person is unable to invest but ask one
of the three to invest
importantly the request actually not
even binding that's the red player
the red player has essentially one scene
has been to happen is incentivized
that that happens so this is kind of
what this looks like you would get like
three different players here and you can
essentially decide
whom you would like to to ask and it's
set up of course that you can see the
gender some are male and some are
female now women are way more likely to
be asked
this is the total times asked to invest
for
male and female players is the relative
frequency you essentially see the
distribution
here is why shifted to the right for
women
compared to men now
is it better to ask a woman but absent
the requests invest the investment rate
actually does not
differ by gender but when asked to
invest women are more likely to comply
so when the woman is asked to invest 76
percent of women in best compared to 14
but not as
in contrast men are also more likely to
invest when asked but it's only 51
percent compared to 14
when i'm asked so the marginal increase
of being asked is higher for women
than for men so if you're thinking about
like who should you ask well
you kind of want to ask a woman because
a woman is more likely
to comply with your request and so now
if
women and women are more likely to be
expected
to say yes they also ask more so that
sort of says you know the gender
differences get amplified by increased
demand for women to contribute
but particularly if there's a man and a
woman where both you think about like
one of them could do it
the man will think well the woman will
do it anyway the women will think well
the man is not going to do it and he's
going to think that
i will do it anyway and so then the
woman ends up doing it
more in addition when there's an
opportunity to ask somebody but asking
is kind of costly and you just want to
find somebody who will do it well whom
will you ask you ask the woman because
she's more likely to comply more likely
um to say yes
let me sort of summarize what we
discussed
so first is large gender wage and
earnings gaps
they have been reduced due to
technological advances and other
improvements over time but they're
there there are so persistent gender
differences
in the us and many other countries
biased beliefs and identity concerns
play in a major role in explaining
those differences um
in addition there are some feedback
mechanisms between the demand and supply
of non-promotable tasks that could be
that are potentially quite important
because i showed you only a lab
experiment but these could be really
important
in real world situations so not only is
it that
what matters is what women decide to do
but also what they're asked to do by
others in part as a response to their
propensity to say
yes or no to certain tasks um better
understanding these issues can now help
us
mitigate the gender gap and we can sort
of then by understanding these issues
better and particular beliefs you might
be able to
improve uh or correct bias beliefs and
therefore
um close on the gender gap potential
what's next in the next few lectures
lecture 19 we'll talk about frames
defaults not just in mental accounting
please read major and share
and lecture 20 we'll look about talk
about malleability malleability and
accessibility of preferences
please read ariely 2003 for that
that was all i have to say and um thank
you so much